china is still showing its anger over
house speaker nancy pelosi's visit to
taiwan this week china has dispatched
naval ships and warplanes for a second
day in a row and launched missiles into
the taiwan strait as part of the biggest
military drills ever seen in the region
speaker pelosi is still defending the
visit our former beijing correspondent
remy inocencio is watching this story
for us raymie good morning
good morning nate on top of china's
second day of military action around
taiwan beijing is now suspending or
canceling eight areas of cooperation
with the united states that involves
everything from military defense to
cross-border crimes as well as climate
change but for taiwan day one was
already one of beijing's biggest live
fire drills against taipei ever
this show of force and fury
of china intimidating taiwan
is what beijing wants washington and the
world to see with more than 100
warplanes warships and a nuclear
submarine deployed into the taiwan
strait and missiles rocketing into the
skies beijing is enraged after house
speaker nancy pelosi visited taiwan this
week meeting with president taingwen
despite beijing's warnings
today at the u.s embassy in tokyo she
said her trip was not about changing
taiwan's ties with china or asia it's
about
again
the
taiwan relations act the u.s china
policy reiterating that the u.s has a
legal duty to give the democratic island
of 23 million the means to defend itself
if threatened the taiwan strait is a
shipping bottleneck more than 80 percent
of the world's biggest cargo ships sail
through taiwan lies less than 80 miles
off china's coast at their closest point
in a first chinese missiles are believed
to have flown over the island others
landed in japan's waters also
unprecedented secretary of state anthony
blinken weighed in from cambodia there
is no justification
for this extreme
disproportionate and escalatory military
response
and china will continue that response
through sunday many believe a precursor
to an eventual full-scale invasion to
unify taiwan with china by force if
needed
and the tension keeps rising in the past
few hours china announced it's now
placing sanctions on speaker pelosi as
well as her family but nate those are
pretty much symbolic
raminosencio in london thank you